welcome to this video playing gin the
man and let's do this clay the column is
quickly going for an active set up on
the queenside all right i'll set up
uh-huh okay set up a stone wall Wow and
everything played like in an instant ok
so I'm activated the Queen and
threatening or planning to play a five
maybe I could have played you five firm
and even the most before but it's it's
not so bad and I love it if they play in
something okay
here what is this position the night
doesn't have many squares I wanted to to
a second but I'm not sure at all that is
working age six the age six it doesn't
really attack the night now if I take it
here takes Queen takes he's got Queenie
seven the real problem is I have a dead
bishop here b3 Bishop e3 would be like
heaven yeah whatever
yeah the problem is he's not detecting
it not at all in one
yeah it looks very dangerous fine
there's also f5
I just take this yeah it's one of many
good moves takes Queen e6 is checkmate
I'm also threatening night g7 queen edge
from so this 151 and take g7 Queen takes
it's probably not totally conclusive
yeah come on take on a two ok then I
just returned and play this position
it's a pawn enter that's just a win
check
but Queenie five Jack so 96 is not
winning unfortunately Kim I could have
taken I could have taken yeah probably
not the end of the world
cannot take Queen g7 made
hmm isn't this our winning actually yeah
but it's really a really bad player but
I'm but I'm doing yeah completely
unnecessary complications
look she says in Luke g6 yeah come on to
keep it simple
yeah winning king and porn and game it's
really a bit a bit meager compared to
what I had before but ok win is a win
check check check check me yeah talk
about the technical plane let's see how
I could made him I mean like the round
here there should be there should be a
meat ready that's if I if okay and maybe
that wasn't one computer doesn't see a
maid all right yep oh this is already
winning this position even as winning
for white yeah I suspected that somehow
but you're never sure Queenie 70 is the
calmness answered by a form yeah I can
activate the bishop and he doesn't
accomplish the same thing for his phone
alright thanks for watching